she lost the primaries in 2008 she lost
the election in 2016
despite having nearly every advantage
now Hillary Clinton's making excuses for
the next presidential Democratic ticket
ahead of the game
preemptively pinning the blame on
Facebook Facebook is not just going to
reelect Trump but intends to reelect
Trump this is a global company that has
huge influence in ways that were only
beginning to understand trumpian
conspiracies might be a big external
threat to the Democrats in Clinton's
world but she's got more shade to throw
at forces from within her own party like
the Socialist sensation from Vermont he
was in Congress for years he had one
senator support him nobody likes him
nobody wants to work with him he got
nothing done
then there's the new Democratic
presidential candidate on the block
Tulsi Gabbard Clinton thinks she could
be in bed with Washington's favorite
boogeyman the Russians they've got their
eye on somebody who's currently in the
Democratic primary and are grooming her
to be the third party candidate she's a
favorite of the Russians they have a
bunch of sites and BOTS and other ways
of supporting her so far the sure is a
lot of blaming going on surrounding an
election that hasn't even happened yet
but it's no secret Clinton's got an axe
to grind she's been blaming anyone but
herself ever since she lost the election
in 2016 I was on the way to winning
until the combination of Jim Comey's
letter on October 28 and Russian
WikiLeaks
I inherit nothing from the Democratic
Party what do you mean nothing I mean it
was bankrupt it was on the verge of
insolvency the voter suppression that we
now know had been in the works and
really put into effect and then let's
not forget sexism and misogyny but if
you think she's the past think again
the DNC just released its 20/20
committee nominees those responsible for
the party's ideological future and the
vast majority are connected in one way
or another to the defeated Clinton Carol
Browner appointed to the DNC in 2016
by Clinton Bakari sellers a surrogate
for Hillary Clinton in 2016
Craig Smith senior advisor to Clinton's
campaign and let's not forget John
Podesta the controversial chairman of
the Clinton campaign itself whose
alleged emails back in 2016
shed light on the inner workings of the
Clinton clan it's clear the Clinton
agenda lives on she doesn't even need to
run for president again although would
you be really surprised if she did why
can't she let go of her losing there you
go again thinking that she's hanging on
to the fact that she lost a rigged
election there you go again thinking
that she cannot understand as she was
simply voted out or that America said no
don't you understand that it's natural
for somebody who is elevated to the self
exalted role of the obvious candidate to
believe that there was a conspiracy
Russian hacking Russian involvement
Facebook Zuckerberg now I always thought
and many people I know below thought
that he was part of the deep state that
he was on her side he's against her
what's happening right now is you're
seeing the old-school DNC that Nancy
Pelosi has been trying to control
fighting against this new left move
there there's a lot of progressives and
and young people who want to see who
have no interest in Joe Biden but if you
say who are the DNC who are Democrats
today I'm telling you right now
Democrats are really Republican lights I
know what I'm saying is absolutely
heretic oh I know what I'm saying nobody
believes this because you think most
people think that there's this that
America is against Trump and
pro-impeachment most Americans have no
idea what's going on they worry about
schools and crime and their children
they have no interest in this they're
just regular folks
you